mic is sealing up the Oval Office
because there's a contagion out there
fortunately we're safe and no one else
is getting in is that you dad what not
contain there's an ignite and turn it
off
not so how is wrong with you you know
that picture where JFK jr. all crawled
out of the death everyone loved that so
now they'll all love little done Don
you're hiding from robert muller aren't
you
busted well at least he's being honest
sir that's my boy totally transparent
now sit down on the couch and don't
touch anything
now watch daddy tell everyone what to do
it's time for executive orders
[Applause]
first up a huge iceberg broke off of
Antarctica the same week that that
psycho Joe Scarborough broke away from
the Republican Party
so executive order Joe Scarborough and
the iceberg have to trade places
Scarborough has to live in the South
Pole and the iceberg has to sit next to
that bloody face low IQ makeup well you
really hate women dad it's like if they
won't have sex with you you're all
pissed and then if they do have sex with
you you'll lose respect for them because
they had sex with you it is a trip okay
all right
okay how about a little less
transparency daughter okay I know I'm
chill Mike why are you sitting all the
way down there
you're not distancing yourself from me
and my family are you oh no no sir of
course not no I'm happy to there we go
then why are you hosting private
meetings with big Republican donors at
your residence this better not be what
it looks like you are by no worm Oh what
no sir no no I know what you're getting
up but it has been the honor of my life
to serve as your vice president sitting
at your right hand the way that Saint
Peter will sit nice try my god okay
executive order no guys named Mike from
Indiana who have never done cocaine can
be President well no that's that's not
fair sir as I'm talking about you I can
pretend to be weird
that's hilarious dad because at first
Mike had no political future without you
and now he only has a political future
without you
timon funny Jesus this is why we're in
so much trouble do you ever shut up yeah
when you divorced mom I shut up and not
talking for a whole year best year of my
life moving on this morning Republican
senators released their new plan for
repealing and replacing Obamacare and it
still might not pass this thing is dying
a slow gruesome death
so executive order we need to pass a
health care bill for the health care
bill sure it has a pre-existing
condition yeah suck you suck yeah yeah I
stuck but that's no reason to deny it
coverage we'll call it the a HCA HCA or
a cha-cha-cha
[Laughter]
it's so funny because it's not even
about health care repealing Obamacare is
all about tax cuts for rich people like
us if we really cared about lowering
health care costs we'd move to a
single-payer system so we could
negotiate prices with providers god damn
it get back under the desk right now
what's the whole thing with Obamacare
was that a black guy told us to do it
and we did not like that and then and
then you said he was born in Kenya but
you knew no no you knew he was born in
Kendall I could not I did not
hey you around for president cause he
wanted to renegotiate the apprentice yes
yes that no no no no no no no no no no
charlie remember when you got all
dressed up to go to Chelsea Clinton's
wedding because you thought you were
invited but you were actually not
invited at all Mike will you stop him
oh no you're upsetting the president
please stop oh yeah no no I will
remember when you came downstairs Nick
at that time in your Fupa got stuck in
the banister and then we realized your
pubes look like Captain Crunch yeah
you're a low quality person you're a low
quality person capturing the cradle dad
no more transparency executive order